well then take your questions on that
thank you very much today the college
discussed the strategy with Africa which
will be adopted by written finalization
procedure and presented to you by my
colleagues user Burrell and Yuto
beelining vice-president Java and
Commissioner Dahle also presented the
January Quality strategy which they will
present in detail to you tomorrow here
in this press room the college also
decided to register a European cities
initiative entitled voters Without
Borders full political rights for EU
citizens you can find more information
in a press release online furthermore
Commissioner kiriakidis gave us an
overview of the state of play the
coronavirus of corporate 19 outbreak and
the current and future steps taken by
the member states with the support of
the European Union as you know the
Commission set up a new website which
continuously provides day-to-day
information and updates for citizens so
back to the climate law we adopted this
morning I'm sure you have all heard what
President on the line had just now to
say about this and very little to add I
think this law is about showing that EU
means business when we pledged to make
Europe climate news for by 2050 it will
help us to stay the course amidst the
many other urgencies that will come our
way in the next 30 years so will allow
institutions when there is another
crisis to focus on that as we need to do
now on the refugee crisis or the
corporate crisis at the same time it
will make sure we stay on track to reach
climate neutrality by 2050 and it is
also something that entrepreneurs and
investors have been asking for give us
give us some clarity give us a clear
course that you will stick to so that we
know where we need to invest and that we
know where to avoid standard assets etc
and of course it is a clarion call to
our partners worldwide to join us in
this journey you know we pledge to be
the first climate neutral continent by
2050 but at the same time it's also an
open challenge to others try and beat us
this is sort of a a race I like to be in
everybody wins
the proposal for a European for a
European climate law sets the goal of
reaching Netzer emissions by 2050 a goal
that was established by the European
Council with full support of the
European Parliament in other words we
will continue on our path of reducing
emissions as far as possible and we will
balance any outstanding emissions with
new carbon sinks and storage of course
many people are keen as I've seen
everywhere to hear the Commission's 2030
targets to those I say that our work to
assess the impact of the new 2030 target
has started and is ongoing and as you
know we want to find out what the best
landing zone is if we want to get to
from 50% towards 55% emissions cuts in
2030 to do that will require huge
efforts by all and that is why we don't
want to make thoroughness and detail the
victim for political expediency I'm I'm
absolutely convinced that the Commission
were to today announce a number a figure
that has not been fully assessed for
impact then we would have an endless
discussion over many months whether the
Commission is right whether this is day
whether the the assumptions are correct
whether the facts are correct etc and we
would lose a lot of time so to those who
say when you come at the end of the
summer with your number you've lost time
I would say with my experience for
instance with the classic strategy if
you do an impact assessments so that the
facts are no longer disputed you can
move quicker also in the legend
process so once we've done this work we
will propose an amendment to the climate
law that we are presenting today and we
will put a 2030 target in there
as well in addition grocer proposing to
set the path for emissions reductions
from 2030 to 2050 based on the best
available science so the European
climate law will set all the targets we
need but of course it also requires
tools to make sure we're hitting these
targets we will build on the existing
governance mechanisms for the energy
union and link our work with a five-year
lea global stocktake under the paris
agreement where we see that collective
action a national action is not in line
with its directory we've set then we
will make the necessary proposals to
correct that first of all from 2030 on
we will monitor our progress every five
years and if we find growth track we
will adjust the trajectory to be sure
there are not many different lines
between 2030 and 2050 one can draw at
the end of the day it's about hitting
climate neutrality in 2050 and to be
perfectly honest with you I remember
very well my experience with the Lisbon
strategy if you have a strategy but you
want it to succeed you have to be clear
about the intermediary steps you take to
get there otherwise the strategy remains
a thing of words and ambitions but not
of concrete results so what sort of
proposals could we then make if it is
necessary to correct the course that
could be proposals for additional and
stronger binding EU action for instance
with regard to the ETS system the
renewable energy directive and co2
emissions performance standards for cars
and bans Loulou CF as we call it land
use and land use change the regulation
or the in energy efficiency directive
and to make one thing perfectly clear we
will make those proposals and this will
be done according to the existing
legislative rules with full powers of
the part of the coal legislators
Parliament and the council that doesn't
change they remain in charge of
legislation the decision of legislation
we remain in charge of the proposals
so it could also be that we make
recommendations to member states for
national measures let me say a few words
about adaptation whatever we achieve in
the next five years and indeed the next
30 years we will still have to prepare
to face the impacts of our changing
climate you know the the time has common
come and gone where we could say let's
not talk about adaptation because that's
sort of almost like admitting defeat
adaptation is an essential element of
our strategy and I've just come back
from Africa and there it is very clear
that adaptation measures are urgently
needed and that we will also have to
take our international responsibility to
help African countries do that but also
increasingly in Europe especially in the
Mediterranean area we see that
adaptation is more and more important
floods in one corner of Europe doubts in
another corner forest fires wildfires
crop failures we need to adapt to a
situation that is already changing the
European climate law will also require
member states to enhance their adaptive
capacity and strengthen their resilience
and our collective resilience so we will
follow this up with a new EU adaptation
strategy which will come out later this
year the final thing I want to touch on
today is action by citizens and by civil
society we want to launch a European
climate pact to help Arneson channel
everyone's efforts to change the way we
produce consume use and reuse and
discard the big and small pledges that
we take every day to ourselves - to our
loved ones to our friends to our
neighbors colleagues so employers and
employees we see this also the
commission our commitment to be climbing
neutral by 2030 has direct consequences
for everyone in this institution and
we're seeing this every day when we're
mapping out what needs to be done so we
want to collect all the knowledge that's
out there we want to share it and we
want to inspire each other to step out
of a carbon fueled world towards a
decarbonized world that is healthier
cleaner safer and
more sustainable and we will leave no
one behind
so we were inspired by grassroots
movements as you know this morning a
present from the line had invited get a
tumor to assist at the beginning of the
college meeting and to share have you
with us and as I said to her this
morning I'm sure that without the
movement she has inspired and is leading
probably today we would not have a green
deal and probably today I would not be
talking about something that is quite
unique and quite forward-looking this
climate law
I've listened carefully to Gretta and
the message I take away from her words
is this planet doesn't belong to those
in power for the generations in power it
belongs to the whole of humanity
and I feel a strong responsibility I
have kids in her generation I'm
fortunate enough to have kids in the
Millennial Generation and in the
generations II and I feel strong
responsibility that together with them
we should make sure we make a success of
European climate neutrality by 2050 and
as I could repeat time and time again
when people are saying this is about
saving the planet no it's not the planet
can take care of itself and if we're too
much of a nuisance the planet will get
rid of us like the planet got rid of
other species before this is about
saving humanity this is about creating
the right conditions so that humanity
can live in balance with its natural
environments in a way that is equitable
and in a way that does not say to those
in the world who aspire to our level of
life to who aspire to live like us to
say to them no that's not possible
because Mother Earth could not afford
that yes she can
if we adapt if we do this if we stick to
this road then we can reach this this is
a problem that is huge is is existential
but it's also a problem that can be
fixed thank you very much
very much and we will not have time to
take a few questions I'll start with
marine here in the front hello having
come from the Financial Times I have two
questions given the sensitivities around
the 2030 target and you know the lot of
criticism that you've come up with I'm
wondering why you chose them to also
apply interim target every five years
using a delegated act I mean this is
hugely politically sensitive and I mean
some could say this is just like waving
the red rag in front of the ball that is
the Member States who don't like this
and secondly it's not clear in the draft
and also your comments that what exactly
will happen to a member state that is
not abiding by the targets or the
trajectory set out in the climate law we
know that the Commission has tools like
infringement procedures or possible use
of the semester can you tell us actually
what you think and if you don't yet know
when will we know what you're thinking I
don't I don't think it's it's such a big
deal what instrument we use and if
that's going to be the discussion and
I'm happy to talk about that till
Kingdom Come the thing is we're talking
about the period 2030 2050 so the first
time the Commission might have to use an
instrument to correct our path will be
in 2035 so I wonder what everybody's so
terribly excited about if if by then we
might have other instruments or if they
need other instruments but somebody's
got to be the TomTom and this somebody's
got to be sat-nav and this somebody's
got to tell us at some point whether
we're still on track or not and and I
think the Commission is best place to do
this this is what we're now doing also
with our into the impact assessment on
2030 we will we will the impact
assessment will help us to say where we
need to be in 2030 whether it's minus 50
or up to minus 55 visa vie 1990 and we
do this on impact assessment and I think
that we should be doing this starting in
2035 exactly the same way
see where we go and then if necessary
adapt it and we think that's is best
done by the Commission if others feel
they're better place to do that fine but
I think this is the most rational thing
to do so it's only about the term
the trajectory it's not about the
legislation that will be needed to
correct that there the Commission can
make proposals and the co legislators
retained full power to decide whether we
do it or not
now your second question what you do
with member states that don't comply
well the thing is the commitment to be
climate neutral by 2050 is undertaken by
the member state so I think it's only
just that we sort of remind them of
their own commitments and try to keep
them on that track it shouldn't be
through punitive measures I think
political pressure is going to be much
more effective here but then again I'm
confident that these for instance the
ones I mentioned these legislative
measures where we decide by qualified
majority could help us bring this
forward the Commission will make a
proposal and then my qualified majority
parliaments and a council will decide
that's a community method that will
apply here and it will not change the
only thing that Commission proposes is
to set the trajectory by an act that the
Commission could do on itself if there
are better ways of doing that I'm
completely open to discussing it but if
that is the main issue here today then
I'm happy then apparently all the other
issues are fully embraced by members of
the European Parliament and others
it's gluten no pun intended
thanks then so on the 2030 target you've
been asked by 12 Member States to bring
forward the deadline of the impact
assessment from September to June but as
your impact assessment will take into
account the any CPS and three of those
12 countries are yet to submit them they
are now going to tell them to do their
homework in time is that being a bit
hypocritical and then on the 2050 target
the climate law says that you won't be
doing an impact assessment because the
existing work from 2018 is sufficient
does that risk saying that sort of mixed
signals about whether an impact
assessment is the best course of action
the letter of the 12 member states asks
us to do it quickly but also thoroughly
yeah that's the whole point if I put
quite a lot of pressure on our services
to be as quick as they can but if they
tell me if you want it to be thorough
and and if you want it to be correct we
will need until at the end of the summer
to do this I have to respect this I have
to respect this I I choose this above
the possibly politically more attractive
option of now putting it immediately
into I would love to be able to do that
or even before the Sun but if if our
experts say that in good conscience they
cannot deliver that before the end of
the summer or the middle of September I
will respect that and by the way thank
you for pointing out that we're still
waiting for some of those member states
who through their own homework and I saw
sort of could could respond in the same
way you you just did and say well do
your homework and then your plea will be
slightly more credible on the second
point look it's it's it's relatively
although complicated but still it's
feasible to be very good on impact
assessment for 2030 but then if you move
beyond that you know we're talking about
15 years from our 20 years from now 25
30 years from now you have to use the
best available science when you reach
that point to be able to say what is
exactly necessary and of course we will
then also if we want if we need to to
change the trajectory we will use impact
assessment to do it at that time
obviously with the best available
science we will have at that time but
let me also for those who might be
fearful that the Commission would be too
much in charge in all of this if we chop
if we reach let's say for argument's
sake we put minus 55 into the
legislation in September and and and we
reach that in 2030 then the 20 years
that come to go from minus 55 to 2-0 is
pretty straightforward you don't have
huge space to maneuver the the
trajectory will be pretty straight
forward so to the corrections I assume
would we rather minimal and that's why
we proposed this relatively light
instrument to do that but again if by
that time Coletta's latest feel we
should use other instruments that's not
the the thing that's going to keep me
awake at night what's keeping me awake
at night if we don't just sear off the
course to reach the targets in 2050 hi I
have two questions as well the first one
is why took the college meeting an hour
longer than and I'm planet has anything
to do with the climate law and the
second one is Greta tumeric just called
the climate law is surrender actually
why is he wrong first of all the meeting
took long because we had quite a number
of issues on on the table today and the
one that was dealt with most expediently
was the the climate law because there
was a large consensus around the table
so that didn't take that long but we
have other other issues on the table in
Europe and those where the reason why it
took longer
anticipated later toon but she explained
this morning that that her approach the
issue is based on sort of the carbon
budget approach which is a different
approach than the one we choose and when
you go up from the carbon budget
approach and then the most cautious the
most cautious approach or assuming that
there will be a number of
disappointments and in our view a number
of technologies that will not be able to
deliver what we supposedly deliver then
the targets should be much higher for
both 2030 and 2050 that is her analysis
and I think there are a number of NGOs
out there who agree with her on that I
tried to explain to her that our
approach is different and that our
approach is based on us reaching carbon
neutrality by 2050 and secondly that we
are more optimistic than she is about
emerging technologies that could help us
speed up the process so that that is
that is where we essentially have a
different point of view but I think
these different points of view and
whatever is being said right now don't
take away the fact that without her and
without the the way she mobilized two
generations of young people across the
world we probably would not be
discussing the European climate law at
today
[Music]
bolita in december the european council
there was a sentence in the conclusions
one member state that this state cannot
commit to implement this objective as
far as it is concerned I'm just
wondering where exactly in the draft
regulation this sentence is reflected if
unaware and my second questions in the
draft regulation there is and there is
all the time that the phrase collective
effort or collective action by member
states so does it mean that in 2050
there could be different different
levels fought for different member
states or does it mean that each member
state individually have to be has to be
climate neutral by 2050 I think active
effort means that every member state
commits to being climate neutral by 2050
that that is the answer to your second
question the answer to your first
question there was a clear reference in
the draft regulation to the conclusions
of the European Council and that refers
to also the conclusion you have
mentioned explicitly Catholic your EU
reporter you said that it's a race I'm
just wondering it's going to be a race
with a level playing field favorite
expression of the European Commission
and the EU is looking at supporting its
own countries with a just transition
fund but we also have neighboring
countries and Ursula von der Leyen
mentioned before there's this press
conference that the EU is looking at a
carbon border tax so are we taking an
approach where we will assist you
countries and have an incentive scheme
whereas we are going to take a punitive
approach to those outside the EU it's an
interesting point I also discussed it
yesterday in a teleconference with a
Chinese representative because there are
many questions about the carbon border
adjustment mechanism as we like to call
it the thing is is this we will be
asking Europe
industry to make huge investments to
assure that we are carbon neutral
climate neutral by 2050 if at the same
time we do not address the potential
issue of carbon leakage then you don't
get so higher goals and you weaken the
competitive edge of European industry so
as I've said to to to my Chinese
colleague and to others the best way to
avoid a carbon border adjustment
mechanism is to make sure you go in the
same way that you also make take
measures that take you to conformity
with the Paris agreements if that is
done then there will be no necessity for
a carbon border tax but if it isn't done
I think we're absolutely right and
absolutely in conformity with
international rules to protect European
industry if we do take those measures
and then a carbon border tax might be
the instrument there might be other
instruments you could look at ETS and
other instruments but we will protect
European industry if it takes the
historic step of decarbonizing in the
next generation
you
hi over here on weekend with the
Austrian newspaper depress what was mr.
Berg's response to your intervention
because taking judging for what she's
currently saying the European Parliament
you didn't seem to make much of an
impression on her and then secondly
closer to home does the Commission
intend to walk the talk in terms of
climate neutrality if you answer any
Commission building it's very rare that
you see an energy efficiency label above
D or C so basically if you want to reach
climate neutrality in 30 years time you
actually need to completely redo or your
your office stock which is going to be
very very costly and you don't have very
spendthrift Member States financing that
and on top of that a final question does
the Commission intend not to take the
plane anymore to go to Strasbourg when
you have your college meetings there but
to actually take the train as everyone
else doesn't as probably mr. McGuirk
would also advise you to do anything
else on the sunny side of things well I
as I said I I gave my point of view to
get the Homburg this morning and
parently she doesn't agree that's fine
we're all striving to achieve the same
goal she has more ambition apparently or
she doesn't think that we can deliver
but I think we can and there we just
disagree and not a problem at all
on your second point we've committed now
in 30 years in 20 years to be climate
neutral as institution so in 2030 this
institution will be climate neutral and
we're now discovering that that is a
huge huge challenge indeed because we
travel because we have many buildings
etc we're all over the world and we're
now doing the mapping and we this is
something that's why I refer to it
earlier in my introduction this is
something that you talk about with your
colleagues all the time this is
something you talk about with those
responsible for the buildings this is
something myself I tried to find out
what the best way is to reduce our
carbon footprint when we need to travel
to Strasburg I've had it I've looked
very intensively etta at our at our car
park how we can make sure that that
there we also reduce
carbon footprint so so so no
misunderstanding this is going to be an
acutely an effort to get there and yes
we're under budget constraints but we've
made that commitment and we want to show
to the rest of the world that we can
that we can do that and now speaking
I've forgotten your third question so I
would ask you to the plights yeah no
I've answered your third question and we
are looking at we're looking at a way
we're looking at a way to reduce to the
maximum the carbon footprint also in our
travels also to Strasburg and I've
noticed that quite a number of
colleagues for instance I don't travel
by plane I travel by carpet I make sure
the car is full so that we use the car
to the maximum effect then we have to
look at what sort of car we use then we
have to look whether the trains provide
the solutions we have because sometimes
we have to travel very early or very
late whether that's possible but we're
all looking into that and we will we
will make sure that we as institution
from the highest level because you have
to lead by example we show that this can
be done and follow us and see how we how
we do it and stay critical if you think
we're not doing to take two more the
lady on the side and then here in the
middle sorry to everybody else today I
know you back for context it's a vintage
drawing those investment Lisa don't do
text heavy circular you never can
objective poll Academy son can't ever
tell model Adriano Salman Dahlia would
like to have some planetary that sabe
please emission carbon Epidaurus
refinery text resources it is a passive
ya plan choice kinabalu created on the
text presidency for sake boom you know
paliotta text key so body text officiel
cement usually confusions l experience
up a player a player sees an age of what
they call y dramatically CQ q
legenda to show to Veda texture kiss
topic of Dada neighborhood la camisa me
le Claire MCC a panel text over Yemen at
an elaborate convert an odd response a
la caída meets angkot HOPWA not room a
lap regiment 2nd ave de foudre our
contribution positive set idea
Domitian negative pursue a lumen de
l'opéra de l'épée develop a planar
service possibility is a video monarchy
at a campo trajectory Norma fair food
near develop a communism in the middle
you
yes sir they see more from your active
oh okay
it's about the social aspects of the
transition to to NetZero defend a number
of concerns have been raised
particularly in countries like Poland
but also in Romania Bulgaria and also by
trade unions that the size of just
transition mechanism is not sufficient
to deal with the scale of the problem
from a social policy perspective so what
can you say to those people today can
you give them guarantees that actually
no one will be left behind our
commitment is that nowhere will be left
behind our commitment is to use the just
transition fun and just transition
mechanism to make sure that in those
areas that are most vulnerable in this
transition we support but we will have
to reorient most if not all the
instruments we use in Europe towards
this incredible transition this is
tectonic this is not just a small change
this is technology that transition to
make sure that we leave no one behind
let me add one thing to this who do you
think who do you think would suffer most
if we did not do this who do you think
would suffer most if we just had this
line of well let's go on like we are
let's pretend there's no problem let's
pretend there's no industrial revolution
going on let's pretend we can go on coal
mining for another 50 years who will
suffer most who will suffer most if the
temperature goes rises above two degrees
and then we reach a number of tipping
points that will create problems in the
world that we can no longer manage of
control who will suffer most the people
who can't go anywhere else
rich people rich people can find other
places they can go high up in the
mountains or in places that or not but
poor people or people who are struggling
with their jobs they can't go anywhere
and if the areas they live in are highly
affected because we are too slow in
making sure we limit the rise the
temperature it's the poor people so
working people that will pay the highest
price so yes we will make sure that our
policies make the transition fair
that we leave no one behind but let's
also be clear about the cost of non
action so if you think avoiding a
transition is possible by buck by not
doing anything you are you're really
really mistaken and mother nature is
reminding us of this on a daily basis
so really the last question mr. Yoshida
don't suppress treasure monsieur le
docteur
simcha the Commission proposed a zoo no
no no that objective put the meat on
carrion said tom says how I'm produced
very keen on position but they are a cop
fancy sagres goo-goo-goo this tea maker
see possibly the counter cameras we do
caucus a possible method upon how severe
myopia a Lucas a digital mom choukaku's
a possible me de la dia same you do that
one submit no songs of a face of etg
impact precision through quatrain hora
debajo de moi the Tsukiji stock emission
Apophis voir a dispute receive calla
lilies etc etc Daniel a patent on a tone
chief reported come la fille de Parma
Opia hace que su Mei NEPA Napa
complement julie asti concern impart
doctor prepare hoc or prefer no passive
R&D basu LeFay edevalla de basura
politic professor Ahmad septum confessor
Mutombo Chico vacuum constabie amplify
vapor lock up the Glasgow
thank you very much detective espera